the man who is 20 to 1 to win this
tournament up there in Lake Tahoe Nevada
is Brian Urlacher joining us here on the
show you know you're 20 to 1 Brian yeah
I think that's a little little to get
romantic last year I was 40 to 1 I
played I think I got like 89th last year
so they had to up my odds or Nick and
Downers that make them up but you know
your odds got well I mean it depends on
if we're trying to make money off it and
very honest you know oh you know it's
not good if you're trying to make well
Lawrence all I'm not gonna Flynn but you
know Todd's went down I guess right
Brian then you look at you know how to
play golf you know how to succeed in
golf in anyway my turn like a
world-class athlete positive
visualization that one positive I'm
positive I just know I'm out I'm also
realistic hmm
so you got to be you know at the same
time you guys know what your boundaries
are on the golf course for me all right
well good I do then let's work let's
work through who else is 20 to 1 Steph
Curry Steph Curry's 20 to 1 can you take
him there last year I think I have to
finish the head of him ok well I just
love why did you before I would go out
how they're playing now because I don't
know how they're playing well I sure I
think I stay out of him well
everything's coming up curry right now a
200 million dollar contract you know
he's got a girlfriend
he's got to be feeling her yeah what do
you think of the NBA contracts in
relation to the NFL players because
that's been something that's been talked
about a lot lately
nope there are their players you did
this a little better job I think of
getting them money and their to their TV
deals I here at the right time any time
I have to get say I'm a deformed ok who
this so that's a lot of guys are getting
paid to like I just really know or not
household names like a lot of money too
so that's good
anytime those guys you pay her heavy for
him all right so 20 to 1 Marshall Faulk
is 20 to 1 and he he told me this the
other day I finally got out of him
because he never mentions publicly what
his handicap is because he wants candy
on the course he said into seven when
you think crap she's better than seven I
know he is Brian all right he said it I
said it he said he's a seven so it said
a lot of people up was lose trying
they're trying to get some suckers out
there to pay attention so was actual
handicap isn't do you think you could
take him I think I finished ahead of him
last year
that's all I can go by I've never played
around the golf with him but you know
okay face by myself what I do last year
and but this year's a different story
because my game is not where it should
be right now
and another twenty to one is sterling
sharp man he hits it a mile staring
sharp please I feel like every year I
played in the tournament there's one I
have in Florida as well
I'm very with sterling and he hits the
ball so good every single time there's
no misfit so what so what is your what
is your handicap what is it um my the
buzz fix right now okay so you can you
can do some damage here Brian Urlacher
I'm looking who you playing with today
will you teen off with momentarily Oh
some people American Century saves the
program so we play with the carcass it's
also the same group last five years was
fun we have a good time so who are you
playing with who are you playing with
when you do tee off for the actual
tournament on Friday do you know I don't
know yet they don't ever released yeah
they haven't relied to no okay both of
you sitting on my phone waiting for that
check so to see do I play with okay very
good Brian Urlacher calling us here
before he tees off at the pro-am kind
enough to call into this show
what is the lovey curse I'm hearing
about you said something about all that
bears have a lovey curse what are you
talking about the interview and some
requests I got so I feel like ever since
love you less they have them bigger its
Olympic versus all I said and then you
know that's now the curse of lovey but
it's true though we're hehehe know that
coach Twitter's love bears have not done
very well
hmm why do you think that why do you
think that is seriously
they haven't played very good god I know
I do it the main reason is if they
haven't scored more points on their
opponents I don't know why I wish I and
I wish they could figure it out - I hope
they know they got some good young
quarterbacks in there I hope they're
both awesome for their sake yeah see
again Brockman can you tell me because
you know we like to create headlines
when Brian Urlacher I know here on the
show we do Brian Urlacher
said the reason why the Bears didn't
play well is because they didn't have
good young quarterbacks on the roster I
like it oh I get that tweet ready that's
a good flip they're like they're rich I
think you could you could edit that well
as you know we always cut around the
right we always cut around the edges
until we can try to finally get you to
say something derogatory about Jay
Cutler you know that
we are everyone's goal that I thought
was unreal to me if I could happen so
she we we spoke I was just gonna play
some time ago the next question I was
gonna cut straight to the chase how do
you think Jane's gonna do in the booth
Bryan I even with Burkhart yeah I like
him I think he's good I think he could I
put them look good first time out same
with Rumble almost with Jim Nantz right
yeah he's with he's with Charles Davis -
oh that's a great that's a great why no
because you don't really have to UM
bigger than tops and layups all game you
know so it'll be easy yeah I think that
they're both still smart guys I think -
you know Jason very well-spoken I think
you'll do well okay
Brian Urlacher joining us here from Lake
Tahoe here on the Rich Eisen show and
now dan Hampton it did say that he
thought that the 80s Bears would have
won four championships if Jay Cutler was
their quarterback what do you think
about that comment that's amazing well
that's gonna be hard to explain you know
I think I ran the ball 80% of the time -
well I mean an Walter Payton they had
Walter I don't run in fact they're
pretty good over 34 is pretty good for
them well they had the fridge - don't
forget yes it was a great runner but
yeah on the goal line
so Superboy great so you you don't think
he would have won they would have won
four championships if Jay Cutler was
there quiet no I did as you know the guy
that had was pretty good to them was
pretty good headline of Brian Urlacher
all right sighs and got it Chris
Brockman headline on it that Dan
Hanson's entitled to his opinion I heard
that
thus Jay Cutler would not have won four
championships for the 80s bears
according to a member trying anything
that hitting would end you know found it
sounds pretty straight that way what you
make it what do you make of Mitchell
true Biscay comments that he told the
Chicago sun-times the Bears would make
the playoffs this year would you think
about that IQ lofty goals now I like it
unlike my golf game I told you I wasn't
going to win he wants to learn right now
so there's nothing wrong with that you
know I think it's hard when you come
from good in college outs or so I don't
know I'm excited wouldn't came to
college but I presume it's hard to come
into themselves how I got a team it's
not good how would you have handled it
if you were in the locker when you heard
it Ricky say that good I mean I
what you guys talking like that I was I
would thinking what if I go I wouldn't
get here like that but this is how you
want to hear guys talking okay I got no
problem with especially as a fan so do
you think the Bears are going to make
the playoffs this year
all right 12th division headline of
headline Brian Urlacher Brian Urlacher
does not think the Bears are making the
playoffs Brockman hits rewording it
again sounds much better uh so before I
let you go on the pro-am this is a very
serious question and you know I take
this very seriously Brian you want to
talk about my hair are you going to wear
a hat playing golf
oh yeah we're happy much every day
that's like I don't like it so Bri I put
a lot of sunblock on you labor I'm a hat
guy on the golf course so I will be
wearing a head and I'll take my hat off
with youth of the round to shake
everyone's hand and does their do you
have hat head I mean is that something
you look at yeah while you are wearing a
hat for real bronze yes show off a hat
head that you never used to be able to
have it's cool to see how many different
directions my hair grows but I kept back
you know I look in the mirror stump I
know you don't have a problem stop at
hosting out now right now you
I got to go they really they would beat
me on the feed right now is that they
want to see me in my big slice i brined
tea and tea and let it fly okay I will
see what bienes Brian Owen the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy